hello I'm Gavin I'm Dan weird the slow
mo guys not in the back garden today
yeah we're here with Blue Man Group
alright lads I always associate Blue Man
Group with you know amazing visuals
creativity and generally just making a
huge mess
but today we're bowling so when you have
a 16 pound bowling ball suspended from
the ceiling it's very important to have
a lot something to catch it with well
luckily slow-mo guys in blue man have
got to fly low in common cuz our first
target it's gonna be multicolored jelly
this could take a while to whisk up in
this giant [ __ ] dan do the honors
absolutely ah look at that
that's absolutely spot good job we
should smash this pretty melts yes we
should yeah
woah hey this bits mine
ah got a good feeling about this one
yeah you ready count it off okay three
two one drop
Oh
[Music]
if we sort of combined a bowling ball
with a cheese grater somehow it would
separate into lovely segments I'll be
even more practical for these guys I'll
be on next collaboration yeah
next feeding time yeah usually I have to
do this on my own you know I usually do
all the crappy jobs
Gavin says he's sorting the cameras out
but he's probably just sitting there
playing games
everything was gets trashed I spent
hours doing this isn't just annoying
yeah you're a really good listener it's
just kind of strange because you don't
really have ears this is definitely the
most important part of the slow mo guys
just the prep and staff and stuff not
the cameras or any be editing and that's
why why she left me but look at me now
you know doing this important work feel
like these sweet bowls but this is what
be on see doesn't have weekends with
first jay-z another power couple yeah
always wondered you know you blew all
over or is it just like just just wonder
you know just curious
what what guess I blew it
nice tack there thank you bet that took
a while it did yeah all right you ready
to smash it now ready okay cool
right three two one drop
bloody Nora see what I am not cleaning
that up well I mean I am NOT cleaning
that up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what you know is useful that is
incredibly it's like a chess toss is a
chance yeah
or chain us chain we should definitely
buy him a cork for his next weekís one
that is out of him yeah dribbly you go
what do you want from me
putting on I clearly can't do it look at
look at sterling my hands are brilliant
response really they're all counting on
you Daniel
god no you can do this just this is a
lot responsibility this is precarious
okay innit I don't wanna waste his chest
juice straight from the heart I sneeze
nobody move slowly back away are you
ready I am looking forward to I'm ready
you get ready as heck good right three
two one drop that made a mess oh that is
a hell of a mess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
got to say I love the 3d effect that
we've ended up here for this masterpiece
yeah I mean now we set out to make a
mess yeah I think that's a great success
- it's probably deadly - so like if you
touch it that good work love it oh we do
we get to keep this thanks guys
excellent Oh brilliant guys thank you so
much
you know I think I'm gonna put this in
my bathroom look at that - buy a mat for
underneath it what do you think well
that was the lovely amount of
destruction but it would be almost
criminal if we made a bowling video
without getting a strike somehow yeah
I'm no good at bowling though so I can't
really do that you are rubbish I've seen
your ball I suggest that we build on
those like learn a ramp cheap things
yeah I think the blue man took it to the
extreme and made this monstrosity so it
looks like something from one of the
rich constructor games that's it yeah
let's hope Makar no but for grown-ups
so we're not just here to make a video
with the Blue Men we also want to find
out what they're made of I do a little
bit of research residents did you know
there's only ever three bloom in any one
time yeah and when a blue man dies they
don't decompose the head just rolls
clean off and then a new blue man is
born from an egg yeah I found these
three heads in a cupboard from around
the corner I think these ones are from
the 90s in the Vegas show actually yeah
so let's ball a ball into the side of
the head and see what these ones are
made off
all right placing bets on what's inside
this one what do you think look it could
be anything
all right I reckon grape juice grape
juice yeah okay are you really doing it
ready right three two one drop
[Music]
what is that it's a cereal Lucky Charms
I feel bad for the blue man having to
witness that one I have bits of skull
fragment right now everywhere else
pretty sure make him do it Yeah right
three two one
my gruesome gosh oh oh that looks like
that looks delicious
[Music]
[Music]
all right final head this one's more of
like a recreation of when I get hit in
the head with a ball yeah side profile
isn't it you didn't have a bowling ball
though no I was all right yeah well
let's see what would have happened if
you were hit by a bowling ball Oh God
all right you ready yeah here we go
okay three two one go oh yeah glad I
didn't use a bowling ball for that
[Music]
[Music]
oh it looks like hunter worms hunter
worms yeah yeah oh or like let go Lowe's
yeah it's like it's a little bit JFK
isn't it if anything I would say it does
go a bit sore back back into the left
and to the left
back and to the left yeah hold on to
your chain us but I kind of my jugular
just anything all righty
yeah no yeah right three two one go
wouldn't that be good in real bowling if
you could do that just start up one down
from the stream I missed so by the time
your ball gets there there's only one
pin up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right in the myth that's silly that is
cleave I feel like for a split second
this pin will this lava lamp was feeling
pretty lucky and they've got obliterated
more than any of the others there's
nothing left of it pretty proud of that
I think the thing that blew my did it
they damn good job with that that's how
you treat your spare well I thought that
was an excellent video I even got a nice
piece of art to take an apt there I
didn't although didn't get messy or hurt
once that about that I've had a word
with the Blue Men and you might want to
strike a pose that's why they
[Music]
[Music]
oh all right
huge thanks to the Blue Man Group for
having us here making this wonderful
video feel free to follow us on Twitter
and make sure you subscribe to the slow
mo guys
yeah can you sign my lab coat Thanks
[Music]
[Applause]